hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel and on this video I'm gonna
give you seven basic tips to take better
photos with your phone coming up I have
a dream how make mistakes but mistakes
make you strong all right let's not
waste any more time let's start with the
first tip the first step and this is
very basic but you need to get cool cell
phone accessories there's two things you
need to get number one you need to get
one of these a cell phone cover that
will protect your phone because it will
fall right everybody's phone fall at
some point in time
[Music]
[Music]
you don't want your screen or your
camera lens to get damaged because then
you won't be able to take any photos at
all with that phone right so I
personally use rhino shield and I so I
got this screen protector and I also get
this cell phone cover this is my
favorite one but I also got a few more I
got this guy not today
I got this one as well I like them
because why number one they have quality
number two their stuff just looks cool
so I reached out to them and asked them
to sponsor this video which they did so
thank you guys so much I'll add their
details for in a video description so
you can go and check them up but the
coolest thing that I like from rhino
shield is the camera lens now it's a 4k
HD wide and macro lens so it's kind of
two-in-one add-on lens and right now I'm
gonna show you guys could be the
difference between taking a normal photo
just with your phone and then the
difference between taking a photo with
the less
[Music]
playing the lens it is something so
simple and yet so many people are forget
to do it is the number one mistake when
it comes to taking photos with your
phone even just your finger prints can
make a great photo look terrible so all
you got to do is just get a little bit
of lint-free cloth breathe a little bit
on it and gently clean it and then the
photos will come out crisp and clear
[Music]
change the camera settings on your phone
I thought that most people know this but
while talking to so many people out
there I realize just how many people
don't know that they can actually take a
lot better quality photos with their
phone by just adjusting the camera
settings so here's what you got to do go
to the camera settings of your phone
then go to picture size and then choose
the biggest size you can also do this
for the video settings on your phone I
mean this is a samsung s9 right but the
rear camera is at a 4k quality and the
front is HD so it would be a very big
surprise to you that most of the videos
that I take on this channel about 90% of
them I've taken with this phone yeah you
got a press focus no Daniel what do you
mean well most people just take the
phone and then boom they take the photo
all right I'm gonna take a photo of this
coffee plant it's so cute my wife got me
but sometimes it's not clear that
picture looks bad because it is out of
focus so all you gotta do is to press
that area on the screen you want the
camera to focus on and voila
[Music]
another tip is to take photos with
different angles now most people just
bring the camera up to where your eye
level is because it's easier right and
then you take the photo but the problem
is all the photos looks the same it
doesn't look interesting but you can
jazz it up a little bit that's what most
professional photographers do and people
don't realize this is that they change
the angle so normally you do this
kinda freaky you do this and then you
get this now what you need to do is this
[Music]
[Music]
lighting now lighting is one of the most
important things when it comes to taking
photos natural light is always better
the light can either make or break your
shot so when you take photos of people
if you're inside a building always make
sure the light is not behind you but in
front of you
[Music]
and if you're outside always make sure
the signs behind the person and not in
front
[Music]
photo editing apps now sometimes you
have those special occasions when you
see family for the first time in years
right and you get some photos but then
afterwards you look at I mean and the
quality is not good because the light is
bad or something but then all you can do
is improve the photo of a cool editing
app like Snapseed where you can change
the feeling of the picture and you can
do so many other things when you go into
the tools area and here you can play
around a lot but for the basic stuff go
into tune image where you can change the
brightness the contrast the saturation
the ambient eye lights shadows or even
the warmth
[Music]
now if you want more tips on how to look
better on photos check out this video
it's really gonna help you out and if
you liked this one give it a thumbs up
subscribe and we will talk soon Cheers
you
[Music]